[Music]
welcome to a special edition LED about
the Olympics you're probably sick and
tired of stuff about the Olympics but
you don't know what we're about ready to
show you maybe so stay tuned you're
going to learn something about the
Olympics today and your salvation wow
never heard that combo before you know
what I mean like I I think that there is
a parallel here and uh hopefully by the
end you won't disagree with me okay see
all right let's go so are you guys uh uh
kind of like Avid Watchers or have you
seen some of the stuff that's been
transpiring I mean we did the show on
the opening ceremony but otherwise I'm
not really watching the Olympics okay so
I looked up a few really interesting
Concepts that happened during the
Olympics this year and there's a lot of
people that get qu disqualified did you
know that I have seen a couple of
headlines for that yeah so here a
British swimmer named Luke Greenbank um
he's from England and he was
disqualified for something really
interesting let's watch this video
British Olympic swimmer Luke Greenbank
is being disqualified from the games for
breaking a surprising rule the
26-year-old finished first in the 200
meter backstroke event on July 31st but
his win an Olympics Journey abruptly
came to an end as soon as he exited the
pool his Elation from winning the race
turned to Devastation after a video
review of the event showed he swam
underwater beyond the allowed 15 M water
mark following a turn Luke who won the
bronze medal in the 2020 Tokyo Olympics
put his hands to his head in distress as
he looked up at the scoreboard after
realizing what happened he spoke to
reporters about the upsetting
disqualification saying quote I don't
know what to say absolutely gut it it's
really annoying I feel like I'm on good
form okay what do you guys think about
that he got disqualified because he swam
too far and broke a tiny rule coming up
just just beyond the line strict rules
that's a major bummer yeah dude imagine
being first at the same time I'm like
hasn't he spent the last four years kind
of training with that rule in mind and
are you good point that's a really good
point and and you know are you are you
pushing that limit so much you're
writing right at the edge that if you go
over you lose it they're probably trying
to get really close that's an
interesting point I want you to bring
this up near the end okay okay so think
about that pushing towards the end
that's a fascinating thing so they said
this isn't the only one that's gotten
disqualified here's a Brazilian swimmer
her name is Anna Carolina Vieira she was
disqualified for something really
interesting do you know why being like
an Instagram influencer and advertising
or something I actually didn't yeah I
actually didn't even know that you you
uh you well I'll let you watch a video
and I'll see it but this is kind of
surprising to me Brazilian Olympic
swimmer Anna Carolina Vieira is being
dismissed from the summer games after
being reprimanded for leaving the
Olympic Village with her teammate and
boyfriend fellow Olympic swimmer Gabriel
Santos on Friday July 26th without
clearing it with the team the Brazilian
Olympic Committee says in a statement
that the head of the swim team
discovered the infraction after Anna
posted photos on social media the
committee also says in its statement
that Anna acted in a quote disrespectful
and aggressive way after she had
contested a technical decision made by
the Brazilian swimming team committee
during the freestyle relay though Anna
denied the claims in an Instagram
stories video published by the guardian
the committee ordered her to return to
Brazil immediately according to the
publication the swimmer says quote I
know who I am I know my character my
nature and that's what matters what do
you think about that I'm sure like those
are just Basic Ground rules right don't
leave without letting us know where
you're going man you make it all that
way you're in Paris you're competing and
to miss out because you wanted to take a
trip yeah you slip do they not know
these rules before they they go here boy
how disappointing and then did you
notice how the country was like you get
back home right now mhm mhm yeah like
these countries have rules right you I
was thinking like wait so she can't just
like travel the world by herself after
that they actually are forcing her to go
home yeah like they care less about you
being the Superstar and could
potentially win they're just like nope
you're done see you go home safety and
protocols wow because the rules are
important right M there was something
else that um um somebody else lost out
for a surprising reason and um check
this out Alex Walsh was disqualified
after initially making the podium in her
lone event Lydia Fielder tracking the
story for us what a a punch in the gut
but it was all over a broken rule it was
ladies no kidding heartbreaking Alex
Walsh was disqualified for an illegal
turn and it cost her a bronze medal it
initially looked like a double podium
finished for Team USA and the woman's
200 meter individual medley the two
Americans you see here Kate Douglas and
Alex Walsh appeared to finish second and
third respectively in Saturday's race
which would have added two more medals
for the US in the pool but very quickly
after this race was over officials
announced they were reviewing part of
Walsh's race they say one of her turns
as she was finishing the backstroke and
going into the breast stroke was illegal
Walsh apparently did not finish the
backstroke on her back while making that
turn into the wall to then start the
breaststroke leg of that race I mean it
makes sense like if if you're if you're
all your competitors are doing it the
right way and you're doing it
differently and you have an illegal
Advantage so you're saying that we need
rules in place so that it's pretty much
fair for everyone yeah I mean otherwise
like with sports it's a matter of
milliseconds milliseconds I mean you're
you're you're talking about somebody
that just maybe didn't pull the stroke
all the way around and just rotated
halfway through that stroke I mean you
think of how would somebody even catch
that to begin with when there's like
water right but they're analyzing it
that closely and that detailed right
yeah nobody's boing about the
rules I mean nobody's going that's not
fair right I'm sure some people are well
sure you can't you can't quite um I
think you know appeal I don't think
maybe you can but it's just like dude
it's on camera evidence is there they
made the decision and they gave that
medal to somebody else the point is like
it's very interesting I didn't know this
many people would be disqualified for
such minute things but it totally makes
sense based on what you said you have to
have some kind of structure you have to
have some kind of rule base right MH
something else that happened that was
very interesting oh this one so tell me
what you know about this uh I mean it's
basically from my understanding this
person on the left in the red IM man
khif had XY chromosomes so genetically
on the inside it's a male but I'm not
sure if this a Dr tonology I think it's
called an INX person where he has female
body parts in the outside and so at
Birth he was G said you're a female
because nobody is going to look at a
baby with like female body parts and
says oh actually we need to test him to
make sure it's a female like you're not
going to do that you know like so that's
what I understand is what happened here
so like I'm sure he has strength of a
male but has the body parts of a female
yeah we don't know the details because
it all goils on to like hormones and all
these things but it is a condition
called
DSD uh very small um percentage of the
world population has this and this
player is from Algeria a a place that is
very let's say not as liberal as the
United States so it's not the case where
when this first blew up a lot of people
thought this was a transgender situation
and that the parent just raised their
son as a daughter growing up that would
not have flown well in Algeria this is
actually a a medical case so I I just
want to point something out that's kind
of very interesting when something like
this happens right we are a society that
gets all up in arms oh my goodness
there's a man in the ring with a female
and he's beating her up and we're like
this is this is outside of what we can
handle right why are we beating each
other up in the beginning true true do
you know I mean like like why does it
take this for us to say isn't that weird
that you're going to step in to a ring
with somebody and try to literally punch
their lights out all right so they're
discussing this um and they're actually
using um uh on Fox News they're using
the girl who um had the transgender swim
or swim against her these last years
maybe you saw that in the news Leah
Thomas was it I think that's her name
yeah interestingly enough Lea Thomas was
not allowed to play in the Olympics
because that's a transgendered case
whereas this was a little bit more
complicated it goes back to the rules
you were talking about how like they
really mul over all of the details and
make their decisions does there have to
be rules absolutely standards otherwise
what what would prevent somebody from
just going oh I want to win yeah I'm GNA
come in there I mean there's even
there's even weight classes for boxing
like they don't put somebody who's 250
lbs in the ring with somebody who's 150
right beair that's a good point that's a
good point even when it's yeah even when
it's mail on meal there has to be like
rules right okay here they are
discussing this um I wish I could say
this was surprising what we saw here at
the Olympic Games of course it's awful
it's sick what that we're glorifying
male violence against women but it's not
surprising because it's the exact same
things we've seen happening in our own
country I I think we all agree that we
want people to be able to live in their
own skin in a way free from
discrimination but that's not what this
is about I guess what it comes back to
is what you just alluded to who watches
that young lady in that video that
Italian boxer who worked her whole life
for that moment sacrificed so much for
that moment literally break down in
tears and say she had to quit the fight
because she was scared she was going to
die who watches all that and says you
know I side with the other person I
don't get that Caitlyn what do you
think I think it's a complicated
situation because like Kenny was saying
it's not a
transgender however it does seem likely
that this individual had an advantage
that made it unsafe for the other person
right khif started coming out in the
news and look at how they started to
spin this and deal with this calling it
bowling
wow and and and she said I want to tell
the world that I'm a female and I will
remain a female I mean that's that's you
know she's basically like what you're
what you're discussing right here by by
calling this foul is is you're bullying
me that's interesting to me
it's again it's complicated because it's
not a transgender person who decided to
make the switch and has an act you know
a male body to a female it's it's a
medical condition so it's it's difficult
to understand um I I think it's
better if this person doesn't fight
against a female I don't know I haven't
been watching the news but I have read
headlines about there are more
LGBT athletes and non non-binary person
as athletes in this Olympics than any
other Olympics in
history so I guess part of me
says if if there's non-binary persons
should there be a category what what's
the
issue I mean at the end of the day are
we being
inconsistent what do you
mean well like they're nonbinary can
they can they compete in either or I
mean that's that's that's my question is
like what what which group are you
participating in and and can you choose
and if you can choose then to me this is
a non-issue it is the next clip I want
to show you is something really
interesting let's move away from the
whole Sports idea and there has to be
rules um I want to talk about something
that I saw pop up in the news and it was
a trans um you know we just had Pride
week so or pride month and so um they
were um talking about this in church and
I want you to listen to what this um
this person talks about um specifically
speaking about God pay attention to how
she addresses
[Music]
God good morning the holy and queer one
be with
you good morning and welcome to worship
my name is Caroline Camp I you she they
pronouns I am the communications
coordinator for Duke Divinity pride and
I am ecstatic to see this worship space
so full and so vibrant with color thank
you all for being here at the first ever
Divinity Pride worship collaboration we
want to affirm everyone to be who they
truly are to step into the holy one's
fire that burns away all that says we
are not good enough and refines Us by
the Pentecostal fire to be who exactly
the great queer one calls us to
be let the spirit move you today lift
your hands and your voices and dance in
whatever way is most freeing for you
absolutely ridiculous Blasphemous on
every level yeah I'm shocked that you
would address God as the holy queer one
I would I would yeah I I wow I when I
saw that I was like whoa whoa whoaa
what's going on here but there's
something I want you to want you to see
as well what what else did you notice
what she was saying
her whole language is very inclusive and
affirming
okay but I I just can't help but think I
go back to Genesis 3 so
much she's allowing or or she's giving
people the space to Define who they are
and if I read the Bible it says you are
not your own you are B with a price
M God tells us you know I know you by
name you are
mine so if I'm not my own am I really do
I have the
right to Define who I am or do I let God
be the one that defines me you're
bringing up a really interesting point
and this I think is is part of the
problem in Eden because it is
essentially the serpent that is causing
e
to question her identity mhm and Define
her own rules Define her own rules and
and who she is because he's saying you
know you're supposed to be like like God
you know your identity isn't isn't what
you believe it is it's something
else
and that was a lie yeah and who wanted
to be like God in the first place was
Satan and that's why he fell from heaven
was cast out and so for him to go to Eve
and say well I've got something more for
you if you eat this fruit and rebel
against God and and not you know go
through with this or not do well in this
simple test then you shall be like God
well who are you talking about she will
be like it's so ridiculous if you think
about it essentially he he causes her to
to go down this this bit of logic that
says you will be more like a
law creating God if you don't abide by
the rules that he's created I believe
that you just look Ates make any sense
that makes sense to me because you look
at our court system right God is able to
summarize your interactions with
Humanity in a fair way in 10 sentences
go look at the law books that are out
there right now we write laws and laws
and laws and laws and laws trying to
make everything fair and we can't even
come to a actual
Fair you know way of presenting it we've
got tons of books trying to explain it
right I'm just saying you're not going
to become more like God who gave Rules
by breaking the rules that he gave yeah
yeah yeah just not going to happen so
another thing I want to point out she
said dance whatever way makes you feel
the most free mhm there's some people on
this planet if you go to the wrong Beach
that think it's very free to not wear
anything at the beach yeah where where's
the line and place limits on uh what did
she say the is it the consuming fire of
God we want to affirm everyone to be who
they truly are to step into the holy
one's fire that burns away all that says
we are not good enough and that's only
to make sure that you feel good enough
to be here it's not for transformation
or salvation or anything it's to affirm
you in whatever you want to do you hear
the word me me me me this is do as thou
will yeah their whole theology here is
instead of saying Jesus died for us to
bring restore us back into His Image
he's saying she's saying stay where you
are yeah and and this reminds me of the
verses uh where Satan tempted Jesus in
the wilderness right he said bow to me
and I'll give you the whole world but
then the Bible says elsewhere that you
can gain the whole world but lose your
soul and it's not worth it yeah
beautiful there's a there's a huge
contrast between do as thou Wilt and
Jesus in the Garden of Gethsemane saying
not my will but your will yeah big
difference and and that's the thing that
that unfortunately and even a lot of
Christians see it this way that the law
is burdensome but Jesus said take up my
yoke upon you for my yoke is easy my
burden is light Satan's yoke is heavy
yeah Jesus is like I want to set you
free I he is the Prince of Peace but he
said but you follow my way and and you
know we think of rules as like oh
they're just holding us back and they're
as drudgery yeah yeah the thing is and
this is what I I like to think about and
ask people is when has God ever asked
Humanity to do
something and it's it turns out like
this is a bad thing for you when is it
ever when is God asked you ever asked
you to do something that hasn't been
designed to be a blessing for you right
I've learned this principle of you know
we are the Bible says we are slaves to
sin right we are basically Satan's
slaves because he's the originator of
sin so as a slave if you're in prison
you have chains on you right now if you
are doing something and you're in sin
but you don't really notice that you are
sinning or don't really see the law as
something that reveals your sin and
don't really care for it you keep
pushing away keep pushing away to you
push away the Holy Spirit who convicts
you of that sin you're going to be very
comfortable you're not in peace not in
genuine peace because you haven't even
experienced the peace yet so you don't
even know what it is because Jesus is
waiting for you to come to him to
experience the peace so you're in Chains
in sin sitting there and as soon as you
realize this is sin I want to come to
Jesus you push and I feel the chain mhm
so you have a decision to make you can
say I want to sit back and I'm just
going to keep enjoying my sins because I
don't want to feel this pressure this
Holy Spirit calling me convicting me
that I need to change because now you
have to do something about it or you can
sayl by your grace I will overcome
because I can do all things through
Christ who strengthens me you are mighty
to save and I'm going to push against
the chain I feel it but he will give you
the victory because the Bible says um
submit to God resist the devil and he
will flee from you yeah here's something
else I want to point out that that is
very interesting in what she said um to
do this in whatever freeing way let's
say you were going to all of a sudden
dance in an inappropriate way is that
respectful to everyone else in the room
mm what if it's not about everyone else
in the
room that's my point so what are these
rules even in a church setting what are
they designed to do there are fences
with God the devil's trying to remove
those fences there are boundaries with
God yes the devil's trying to remove
those boundaries so there is something
kind of holding us back if you would in
a in a good manner saying like don't
cross over into this space because
destruction will happen yeah right
Devil's like no do away with all that
you can go the reality is like what you
said you're ultimately Chained and and
you're in bondage to Satan where Jesus
is setting you free well yeah that's the
thing like Satan has you in Chains and
he says look at God's laws look at the
rules those hold you back I'm not and
you're not noticing you're being held
back but God says it's the opposite with
him he says look I have boundaries and
this is for you to love God and love man
as the Bible says but that sets you free
it's the same thing as when you have a
child and you say don't touch the stove
that's a rule you'll burn your hand you
will hurt yourself and it's like oh man
but I really want to touch the stove ah
and then it's like okay so I told you
that was my rule you broke the rule and
you got hurt God is the same way right
but you know his rules set you free
because it's rules that are based on
love that's right it's very much about
perspective if you think of it like a
walled
Castle on the outside is the
enemy right and the people that live in
inside let's say they they don't know
about the
outside and they think man what's what's
beyond these walls what's beyond the
castle as soon as they get outside and
they experience the enemy guess where
they want to be they want to be inside
where there's walls mhm MH
it may appear to be more free but
there's an enemy out there that wants to
destroy you mhm and so that's that's a
healthy way to look at it you think the
walls are there to restrict you but
inside it's it's actually protecting you
from something that's far more damaging
so the walls protect our freedoms yes is
what you're saying you know this is
another example of people forcing or
trying to conform God to them or their
their ideals or even
they're living out the with the story
with ad and Eve The Serpent and Eve the
serpent the devil promising Eve you will
be like God it was more his
interpretation or what she wanted the
level that she wanted to achieve not
necessarily becoming God and who he is
his Essence his love his character right
because if it's the case come as you are
all right come as you are to a loving
God the god of the Bible why come up
with this queer Holy One something
completely attached from God that we
know it's always a conforming of of what
you're thinking of him to be yes instead
of us submitting to God right we W God
submit to us in in our sinful State when
I first came to church cuz I didn't grow
up a Christian I literally showed up in
purple All Star ripped jeans and a
checkered shirt CU my mom told me at
least wear a shirt to church welcome you
know welcome
exactly because there's something about
that right but God doesn't keep you
there so for me personally this is my
conviction I want to wear something a
bit more dressed up to church because
you know I come before God he's the king
of kings if I'm invited by the king of
England I'm not going to show up in
jeans that's just my personal conviction
but I think that's an example of how God
works with you where you are and brings
you where you need to be with anything
in your walk with him right not just
this is a simple example but just in
anything he says come as you are but he
doesn't keep you there because he has a
better plan for you it's interesting
point you said that that's not your
conviction I don't even think you would
have been allowed in the king's presence
think of the the standards of Court they
the standards to enter a mosque even as
a visitor they have a basket there with
veils to give to people people gladly
put it on have the experience then leave
no problem but when it comes to our
standards in Christianity it's like all
bets are off I'm really glad that you
actually said that candy cuz can you
please read this verse this is from
Psalm
89:7 God God is greatly to be feared in
the Assembly of the Saints and to be
held in reverence by all those around
him exactly what you just said there are
beings that are that are so revering of
God that they don't even want to look at
him they're shadowing their eyes yeah
they're saying holy holy holy right all
the time 24 right and who are we in our
arrogance to be like God is just like
this and we know yeah God's my homie you
know like my buddy okay so I'm going to
I'm going to move on through here um
listen to what they say like you know
when you go to church and you have these
kind of like group things that you say I
want you to pay attention to what they
say call in response yeah kind of like
that so they're starting out the church
service so what I'm showing you is the
beginning of the church service okay and
then I want you to notice what kind of
people are in the
audience strange one fabulous one fluid
and ever becoming one do not not allow
us to make our ideas of you into an idol
you are as close to us as our own breath
and yet your essence transcends all that
we can imagine you are mother father and
parent you are sister brother and
sibling you are drag quean and transman
and gender fluid incable of limiting
your vast expressions of beauty embodied
in US your creation we recognize our
flesh in all its forms is made holy in
you with Thanksgiving we celebrate your
manifestation in all its glorious forms
blessed are our bodies blessed is our
love blessed are we when we celebrate
that which the World Turns away fill our
hearts with a pride rooted in resistance
to all that seeks to destroy
any thoughts yeah no that that's moment
of silence right there we those are the
most normal looking people yeah I was
really expecting you to say I was
totally I was totally expecting like the
crowd to be full of people with flags
and everything like this this just looks
like a normal Church yeah just a younger
audience but but you know isn't isn't
isn't that interesting that what they're
heralding is this idea that God is just
this all-inclusive all everything and
then
she ends the whole thing with help us to
resist against anything that is going to
destroy
but but God God that God is right he is
not a respector of persons yes but he
it's like there she's
saying he's all of these things first
off that in itself is problematic
because God isn't the transgendered man
and and all these different man woman
there is nothing there is nothing sinful
or he is accepting and loving of that
person but he doesn't call that person
in he doesn't call the actions or the
lifestyle of that person holy and I
think that's the biggest deception yeah
because God loves the person but hates
the sinh and that why does he hate the
sin it originated with Satan right and
it's sin that destroys the person he
loves because sin is like a disease that
eats us up and destroys us because it
always turns the focus of one away from
God and others MH into yourself MH it's
interesting why these labels for
instance um a transgendered man is a
transgendered man right that's that's a
small portion of the population and
there's certain criteria characteristics
that need to be met to be characterized
as
such that doesn't apply to someone who's
loving that could be literally anyone
someone who's kind someone who is uh has
a lot of patience and all these things
that is across the board that is who God
is that is actually all inclusive not
these particular labels yeah when Moses
wanted to see God's face what did God do
what did he say he shielded him behind a
rock shielded him behind a rock and then
what did he say let all my goodness pass
before you yes and he said I am
longsuffering merciful kind he says I'm
showing Mercy to those that love me and
you know but that will by no means um um
allow the guilty to to go and see that I
don't understand why that isn't enough
that in itself can apply to every human
being right none of those are like I'm
going to do what I want those are
character traits of God that that that's
who the essence of God is is he is this
loving individual that is very fair and
that is who he's calling us to be but
but he brought in there I will by no
means clear the
guilty this reminds me of this verse in
Romans chapter 1 it says professing to
be wise they became fools and changed
the glory of The Incorruptible God into
an image made like corruptible man wow
good verse history repeating itself I
think something should be said here
that it's fair to assume that these
people are genuine right and with a lot
of the congregants they're there and
they're following the shepherd which is
the person who's reading this this and
leading out in this call and response
and people of influence have a huge
responsibility on their shoulders and
God is going to be looking at them and
holding them accountable for all the
people that they LED in whichever
direction man it's my prayer it's it's a
bit of Hope as well because the Bible
does say the truth will be shared and
people's eyes will be open and they will
make the decision to walk in truth
MH I'm appreciative that these people
are in church that's the one thing amen
right Amen to that but man we need to
pray for a heart conversion of everyone
in that room particularly the one
leading out
because man that uh the consequence of
what's Happening Here is going to be
grave I like what you said here because
this gives me an inspiration like like
get out there go go go and get actively
involved because you know there are
people that are being just like sheep
like led to the slaughter right and so
we need to be able to share the truth I
mean how are they going to know the
truth if no one tells them or confronts
them or or shares it in a loving in
manner yeah and this
um in the corner was like from duke some
Duke University Associated Church yeah
so this is like a so these are not like
just uneducated this person had their
second mdiv that that lady in the front
yeah so it's it's not like they don't
have the capability of thinking this is
somebody that's reading the same word of
God that you are and probably has read
quite a bit of it maybe more I'm
assuming and so so you know it's like
amazing but here's here's here's where I
think a major problem lies if we do not
come to God with a open and humble Heart
Lord teach me if we're trying to find
how the Bible fits into our narrative we
will skip over and and miss the very
things like the Jews right raise Lazarus
from the dead I'm sorry I've never seen
anybody raised from the dead how could
you ever think that was coming from a
bad place
and those people like literally were
like come off the cross we don't believe
you in who you are like a day or two ago
you just raised Lazarus I mean that's
the level of deception that can happen
when you come to God with a preconceived
ideas and not a humble heart and and it
doesn't start here it's like little
decisions little chipping away out of
from what is truth and then we end up we
end up here yep you should always read
the word of God and when you open the
word of God you should go like Lord what
do you want to teach me as I'm reading
this right now yes yep the next clip I
want to show you is a Methodist Pastor
who has been um being a pastor in Drag
and remember keep keep this mind like
like I don't want to get too far away
from why we disc started this discussion
about the Olympics to begin with keep in
your mind that there has to be rules
there has to be these kind of boundaries
there has to be something like this
right we have all these things in our
world that have those rules and those
boundaries what happens when you remove
those boundaries so this Methodist
Pastor right here is wanting to rewrite
the script and he said something really
interesting why he preaches in drag that
the best ways to to enact systemic
change is through um joy and Carnival
drag is Carnival it is over the toop it
is loud it is joyous it is laugh filled
and it is in moments where people on the
margins uh are handed just a little bit
of power and when they hold on to that
power for longer than it was intended
things happen what does that even mean
that that's kind of what I'm thinking
like what what are you
saying I think it was amazing that he
started out and he said look if you want
to change something you want systematic
change right yeah theatrics Carnival if
you give the marginalized power and they
hold on to that power then they can
begin to make those changes happen
because they're holding on to that power
longer than they should have had is that
not like what the whole world is dealing
with right now but look at this idea
right here this this is where the I
believe the the Jewish Nation really
struggled in this area right they're
looking at Jesus going why doesn't this
guy have all this power that he needs to
come and and make us the top dog in the
world that's what they were basically
wanting their savior to be is like you
need to just show these Romans like what
they're needing to do and give us the
power so that we can take that power
back yep rather than Jesus is like you
guys don't understand at all it's about
serving your fellow man coming down from
an elevated position being humble like
Micah 68 right yeah that's not pride no
and I like I like a verse that goes
along with that really well it's from
Amos 33 it says can two walk together
except they be
agreed so unless you and God are on the
same page you know unless you're on
God's page you're not walking together
right right I think something that
really struck me here is
that like it makes me genuinely really
sad because this individual was talking
about happiness and joy and all those
things but again it's like God says come
and taste and see that the Lord is good
right like there's people in the Dark
Ages and we talked about this morning
during work work worship there's people
in the Dark Ages that or well actually
previous before the Dark Ages during the
Roman times when Christians were not
accepted at
all that died for their faith that had
literally got their limbs torn off while
alive that got fileted like a fish while
being
alive and those people would sing songs
and they would go to the Stak wearing
their best clothes cuz they had the
peace of God and they said Lord I am so
thankful for the honor to be tortured
and mared for you that peace can you can
only receive when you're genuinely
walking with the Lord and are genuinely
wanting to follow his principles that
set you free this doesn't give that now
when you have power there are steps that
are skipped here
because they're achieving they're
wanting to achieve happiness and joy
through Rebellion through actions of
rebellion right that's the LIE of Satan
instead of submitting to the Lord having
him do a heart change and then you
living out the the cause and effect of
living out um peace and joy and
happiness what did Jesus go around
giving the
marginalized I wouldn't say it was power
it was a choice MH wasn't it he was
healing them he was loving on them and
then he would say sin no more that's
right calling them out of where they are
into a a whole new way of living a
perspective a transformation to think
about it right that lady who was caught
in adultery it was a sexual sin a sexual
act
if you know these kind of people the
drags
drens genuinely believe that Jesus
accepts them from where they are the
scripture would have been different
Jesus would have said like what are you
guys talking about your Pharisees she's
fine she accept her for what she's like
and keep on doing this but he didn't you
know he he pointed out look this is a
sin I love you and I want to help you go
and sin no more I will give you strength
yet still power is Promised that's the
thing but but to be set free from sin
yes and it's through Jesus Christ it's
through God the paralytic at the pool of
Bethesda didn't Jesus tell him to also
not sin that something worse would
happen to him right something worse
would come upon you right and and that's
kind of insinuating that you know they
he he was somewhat actively kind of he
was responsible responsible for putting
himself maybe in that position all right
moving on uh go ahead and read this
Keith that you put off concerning your
former conduct the old man which grows
corrupt according to the deceitful lust
and be renewed in the spirit of your
mind and that you put on the new man
which was created according to God in
true righteousness and Holiness so what
does God want from you a new man he
wants to reinstate righteousness and
Holiness in you and remove you from
those deceitful things that you think
are all about you and what you want to
do and put you back into God's mind and
using his mind with you yep and then the
second Corinthians 5:21 explains how the
Lord is our righteousness Christ are
righteousness that's right he he is
righteousness he's the only one who can
put on that white garment that covers
you but he's not going to do that if you
don't want to do away with your sin you
have to come to him and say forgive me
Lord for my sin what is sin 1 John 3:4
says sin is the transgression of the law
The Ten Commandments it's that's the Ten
Commandments are here to show us this is
what sin is but it cannot take away your
sin that is what Jesus does as soon as
you come to him genuinely asking Lord
forgive me for my sin and he will
cleanse you from it this is true let's
talk about some rules then rule number
one denique read it one should strive to
act with compassion and empathy toward
all creatures in accordance with reason
what do you think about that whose rule
is this I just I'll get to that what do
you think about
this Tru Damon yes or
no I find it interesting it says in
accordance with reason I would say in
accordance with what the scriptures say
you know you're hinting already on
number one where I'm going with this
what's number two the struggle for
justice is an ongoing and necessary
Pursuit that should Prevail over laws
and institutions wow would you agree
with that
no nothing exactly law and institutions
and like you know the Bible even talks
about respect the government as long as
they are in line
transgress if they're in line with God's
scriptures Alice a Bailey
junk let's read rule number three one's
body is inviable subject to one's own
will alone
alone Yeah so basically um you should
not violate anyone's body unless that
person wants their body
violated that's how I'm reading that oh
okay so what do the scripture say it is
written right like your body it was is
the temple of God because that that puts
you as the yeah you're the one that can
do what you want to do with your body
right read this the freedoms of others
should be respected including the
freedom of to offend what what I should
be a free to offend you wait wait wait
the willful and unjustly encroach upon
the freedoms of another is to forgo
one's own okay I'm going to pull another
it is written right love God and love
man and love love your enemy you can't
just go around offending people no you
cannot and and think about what this is
doing it's like I'm reserving the right
to offend you is basically what this is
say selfishness okay selfishness number
five go ahead Den beliefs should conform
to One's best scientific understanding
of the world one should take care never
to distort scientific facts to fit one's
beliefs so science tells you well we
believe in evolution and the world is
like millions of years old and the Bible
says it's not no no no it's my
scientific belief so let's try this the
science Community now has lots of
different boxes of what you can identify
with is that science did that goalpost
move is that
politics you tell me why aren't the
scientists stepping up Mr scientist in
the room where's the scientist at
yeah I think that's politics what what
you were saying okay candy people are
fallible if one makes a mistake one
should do One's best to rectify it and
resolve any harm that might have been
caused yeah yeah yeah okay you'd agree
with that rule I don't see the first one
we can agree all right here we go last
rule every tenant is a guiding principle
designed to inspire nobility and action
and thought the spirit of compassion
wisdom and Justice should always prevail
over the written or spoken word wow
that's specific that's very specific
this was written by a Satanist ding ding
ding this is the Satanic Temple seven
fundamental rules okay wow so wait let
me tell you something anybody that's
watching out there every single thing
that you have on this planet has rules
so name something that does not have a
rule Why seven like yeah why seven why
you think it's seven right it's a good
question you know what I mean it's very
interesting but do you saw you guys
already pinned out how much self is
included in these rules right I can do
whatever I want to do and I'm reserving
the right to do whatever I want to do as
long as I want to do it even number
three one's body is inviable subject to
one's own will alone so you could say oh
a 10-year-old boy and he's fine with it
and I'm fine with it so we're just going
to go ahead and find a bedroom like
that's what they can say like this
you're bringing up a really good point
because the topic of children being in a
party environment obviously came up
during the Olympics right yes what is
that child doing there is there a rule a
line a something when we're dealing with
like the world and these standards the
world is grappling with right now trying
to figure out a way to do away with
those things I have a problem with that
as a parent I think that's completely
disgusting and there should be some
serious rules now here's a rule that I
could just throw out the window and
never need it again great
yeah does anybody know where this road
is right here okay where is it and what
is it uh Auto Bond that's the Auto Bond
and it has no speed limit have you
driven on it no I wish I drove on it
there is a condition in which it does
have a speed limit if there's other cars
130 is that no if there's fog oh well
then they've got a
rule bam I was trying to find something
that like didn't have a rule it's either
fog or rain or both yeah interesting
well then yes everybody should be
sensitive to um um conditions of the
road if there's traffic you can't be
going 200 miles an hour if there's two
two everybody's all backed up right so
there has to be some rules even when you
say that there are no limits now have
you ever seen pictures of a car crash
when they are going as fast as they can
possibly go oh you be yeah you'll be
dead waa can you tell me what kind of
car this is a Ferrari
okay how many of you have ever seen a
Ferrari that looks like this no this
thing looks like a Transformer it does
caught on fire I don't think that person
lived no and that's what happens when we
don't have rules it's not saying that
because you go as fast as you want on
the freeway that that you're always
going to have a problem I think that in
the long run you run this major risk and
in Christianity we know that you may not
per receive the problem this side of
judgment right right you might not you
you might think you're getting away with
it you might be speeding or whatever
like that but are we willing to take
that risk that we're going to lose out
on eternity because we want to do what
we want to do that's the question MH
yeah Ecclesiastes 12:13-14 says let us
hear the conclusion of the matter fear
God keep his Commandments for this is
man's all it doesn't say this was the
Jews all it doesn't say this was only
the um these other people are every
single person this is your duty why
because it's the most respectful thing
that you could do for somebody else
right I mean this is coming from the guy
who had to handwrite a copy of the rules
and then disregarded them later looks
back in life and says that was dumb yep
that caused a lot of pain and in fact
we're still dealing with Solomon's
messes up today there people in cultic
civilizations that all talk about the
solic this and that the the occult
things that that man got involved in
back there in life have rippled through
time and we deal with it today y yep so
rules are important and we've talked
about this one on our show and I really
hope that you guys if you've made it to
the end of the show you're starting to
see something we began talking about the
Olympics we began talking about rules
and laws right don't be deceived when
you read the Bible and it tells you
especially Jesus speaking right here he
says not everybody who says to me Lord
Lord shall enter the kingdom of heaven
but he who does the will of My Father
which is in heaven what's the will of
God when the man came and said how do I
get to heaven that's a question all of
us have right he says follow the
Commandments and the guy goes oh that's
what I'm doing right and he goes well
love God with all your heart with all
your mind with all your soul and love
your neighbor as yourself and and he
well he said that at the tail end of
that thing he went through and he talked
about the rules right and he left out a
very interesting um bit of rules when he
was talking to that young man and that
man did he do what God was asking him to
do go sell all your stuff and give it to
the poor nope so if God is asking you to
do something and you disregard God who's
the higher
power you are you could care less about
God you're trying to be you're you're
trying not overruling God but you're
basically having yourself as the as the
ultimate God because you're disregarding
what God God's asking you to do
something and Jesus asking that man to
go do that really showed he goes I'm
keeping all the Commandments no you're
not because the God just asked him to go
do it if he's asking him how to have
salvation he believes that that guy is
the Son of God right all right so many
will say to me in that day Lord Lord
have we not prophesied in your name
that's a Christian have we not cast out
demons in your name that's a Christian
we not done all these wonderful things
in your name that's a Christian and then
I'll declare to you I never knew you
depart from me you practicers of what
does that word say Kandy iniquity
iniquity lawlessness people who don't
follow the law is The Ten Commandments
important brothers and sisters I hope
that you are inspired that if you have
grown up with the belief that God nailed
that Ten Commandments to the cross that
we do not need to follow these things um
I hope and pray that you'll actually
just seriously consider these words
right here just go and ask God show me
the truth in this thing is your Ten
Commandments important and if so each
and every one of them is all of them
still valid today and I want to
challenge you we love you guys we know
lots of different people that that that
go to belong to lots of different
churches we all believe in the Sabbath
in this ministry and I just want to
inspire you to look at the fourth
Commandment if you have grown up
believing that that day was physically
changed go and look at the history of
why it was changed go and look at is
that important today is there biblical
evidence if it comes from the Bible and
the Bible supports it yeah we got to
look at that right yeah y but I
challenge you try to find the evidence
for the one verse the one Commandment
that most Christians will disregard yes
and so we should also mention that we
have two episodes coming up soon in
which we show you from historical
documents how the Sabbath was changed to
Sunday also if you watch our most recent
LED video on uh what is the mark of the
beast we show you quote by quote by
quote by quote that the Catholic Church
admits to have changed the Sabbath to
Sunday that it's a Catholic institution
and they themselves talk to Protestants
and say why if you believe in the Bible
and say you are Solo scripture at the
Bible and the Bible alone do you keep
Sunday which is in honor of the Pagan
son God and in honor of us as Catholics
under the pope also this this Sunday 2
days after this has been uploaded so if
you watch this anytime later it will be
on there already we're releasing a
podcast episode with a very own Keith
thater woohoo in which we talk about
these verses under uh Grace under the
law what does it mean how can you guys
say to us that we're supposed to keep
the law when Paul says this well we're
going to that in this Sunday's podcast
episode which you can listen to wherever
you listen to podcast Spotify Apple
podcast or wherever so check that out
and again if you watch this video any
later than two days after this upload
it's already on there I want to leave
you with this one verse Keith can you
read this for
us but be doers of the word and not
hearers only deceiving yourselves for if
anyone is a hearer of the word and not a
doer he is like a man observing his
natural face in a mirror for he observes
himself goes away and immediately
forgets what kind of man he was but he
who looks into the perfect law of
Liberty and continues in it it is not a
for F hearer but a doer of the work this
one will be blessed in what he does
brothers and sisters we want you to be
blessed God wants you to be blessed and
he's giving you the recipe of how to
obtain that blessing I challenge you do
your own research look it up don't just
take our words for it take God's word
for it and find it in the word of God if
you want to check out our Bible study
school Keith where can we find that uh
ls. v/b School yep and another good
resource is sabbathtruth.com you find
all the resources for why Sabbath is
still uh to be kept by us Christians and
if you really want to celebrate and
promote the Sabbath if you're a Sabbath
keeper we've got these awesome t-shirts
Keith's son actually designed this
t-shirt how old was he when he did it
maybe 11 12 yeah something like that
awesome 12-year-old kid designed this
t-shirt you can find that at lightwear
shop thank you guys for listening we
hope that we will see you again next
week please give this video a thumbs up
like it subscribe share this video so
that the truth of of God's holy word get
gets out and if you have any questions
or comments please feel free to reach
out for us we'd love to teach you more
or give you some resources to look into
we love you guys take care
[Music]
Jacob and he for you
Israel make a Piller in the temple of my
God and he shall go out no more I will
ride on him the name of my
God in
and
strength M Dem by Shall
I pray alone but by every word that
proceeds from the mouth of
God all right I can do this
[Music]
all
right there are conventional ways of
sharing the gospel but some may need a
different way of doing things um never
mind it a way that gets the message out
with
confidence wow cool shirt what's the
mean oh thank you you know we're all
made with a unique fingerprint but we're
all God's artwork wow where'd you get
it night wear wear your Witness
[Music]